We are asked to take -6x ^ 4 - 3x ^ 2y ^ 2 + 5y ^ 4
of 2 x 4 - 8 x 2 2 y 2 - y - 4.
I also recommend that you pause the video and try to do it.
All right, let's solve it together.
We'll take out the green polynomial from this purple.
So we can write it like ...
we can actually write
2x4 - 8x ^ 2y ^ 2 - y ^ 4 minus ...
I will write this in brackets,
I will leave a little space ...
minus (-6x4-4x3x2x2 + 5y4)
Note that
I remove this green polynomial with two variables
of this purple polynomial with two variables.
Which is exactly what we are told to do.
So how much will it be?
Okay, I can just copy the purple part.
We will have 2 x 4 - 8 x 2 2 y 2 - y 4
And then I can uncover the braces and change the signs.
The negative of -6x4 is plus 6x4.
So this will be plus 6x4.
The negative of -3x ^ 2 ^ ^ will be plus 3x ^ 2 ^ ^.
And then, finally, but not least,
we have minus or subtract plus 5 ^ 4.
So this will be subtraction of 5u ^ 4
or -SO4.
And now we can try to simplify.
Let's first look at this article here.
We have 2 × ^ 4.
And what we see is another member with x degree four.
We see it here.
So we have 2 x 4
and we can add it to 6x4.
How much will it be?
If we have two of something and then add another 6 of this thing,
this will be 8x ^ 4 ...
... 2 + 6 is 8.
2x4 + plus 6x4 will be 8x4.
And now we have this member with x ^ 2 ^ ^.
We can say we take 8 of them.
Here we add 3 of these members with x ^ 2 ^ ^.
So we can collect these odds.
If we remove eight, but add three,
we can treat it as
-8 × 2 × 2 × 2 × 3 × × 2 × 2 × 2.
Okay, how much is minus 8 plus 3?
This will be minus 5.
-5 × 2 × 2 ^ 2.
So this is this article.
Let me write it a bit clearer.
This is the article here.
Do not forget to include this sign.
Removes 8x1, 2u2,
you can do that as -8 x 2 2 x 2 2 plus 3 x 2 x 2 x 2 2.
Last, but not least,
subtract one u ^ 4 and then subtract another 5 ^ 4.
How much will it be?
You can see it as -1x ^ 4 - 5u ^ 4.
Minus 1 minus 5 is minus 6.
Minus 6u ^ 4 ..
And we're ready, we're out
this one.